go baby remain above a family believe
let me mmmm believe it huh
hey guys I have something very important
to tell you
I am quitting YouTube forever raah
see that's why I'm saying this is what
this is what people do this is this is
what they do
hey what's up everybody uh this podcast
is actually not going to go on the other
audio platforms this is just going to be
a YouTube exclusive thing because it
just pertains to the YouTube viewers now
I've read in quite a few comments
recently people are a little upset a
little angry at the fact that I didn't
give anybody a heads up that the channel
name was changing the genius brain and I
was going to be doing a podcast from
here on out but I did didn't on
Instagram a few times didn't on twitter
twitter quite a few times but uh i guess
a lot of people don't follow me on my
other platform so [ __ ] you guys I'm
kidding but in all seriousness let me
just give you the the thought behind why
I didn't decide to say it on my youtube
channel number one I just didn't want to
make a big deal out of it specifically
because the content that I have on this
podcast is essentially me and so when I
was reading comments like yo how are we
supposed to know that this was you I
don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe the face
that's on the thumbnail my actual
[ __ ] face but other than that I
understand like I'm just being a [ __ ] I
understand what you mean by it it's just
I didn't I don't want to make a big deal
of it like I just I kind of decided to
go all-in and that's just who I am as a
person I didn't want to just put like
one foot in the water and then see what
happens I'm kind of more like a dive
all-in type of person it's what I did
with film it's what I do
so I knew with YouTube in general so for
a while now people have been asking me
to start a podcast and I just couldn't
add something else onto my plate number
one I have a lot of businesses that I'm
looking over right now obviously with
other partners but there's still a lot
of work to be done with that on top of
that I still I'm still writing I still
want to do film so
still doing that I'm still acting I'm
still auditioning so there's a lot of
things going on right now and one of the
things that I told myself this year was
that I wasn't gonna go back into that
old habit of just trying to be a jack of
all shits right meaning that I'm trying
to be good at everything because that's
not possible you have to in order to
master a craft or really be good at
something you have to just focus it one
at a time and so in order for me to do
that in a creative space I have to
figure this out and you guys might be at
this crossroads one day to is where you
have to really figure out what you're I
guess what's the word I'm looking for
like the overarching goal is in your
life and it turned out for me it was to
feed my artistry meaning that I had to
feed something that made me happy yeah
money makes me happy I always joke about
money and you know obviously when it
comes to this podcast was it a great
financial move in terms of my channel
probably not man like I'm not really
making much off this channel now
especially ever since I started going to
the podcast some of you [ __ ]
that like I abandoned the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you which I did not it was just a
different platform so let me just so
that's why I'm taking the time to
explain myself right now I wanted to do
a podcast and I had to do it all the way
because I didn't want to half-ass things
which is basically what I'm getting to
podcast number one it's a great platform
for me why because it's what I do in
general it's something that I already do
when I was helping startup JK news it
was almost like an extension of what I
was already doing on my channel I was
taking like hot topics which if you guys
watched me starting seven to eight years
ago it's essentially what JK News was
right or is right now it's just talking
[ __ ] about having fun with the current
hot topic whether it was something that
happened on the news or whatever or it
would be thoughts that I had and so
that's what this podcast is right this
podcast is my vlogs but the difference
is that you guys get to have a longer
format of it I get to speak longer and
clarify what I'm saying joke a little
longer and then on top of that bounce
off ideas off of somebody else and that
person who's brought onto the podcast
and can basically give me more material
or they could change my mind or we could
have an open discussion about certain
things that that we can agree or
disagree on either way it's the same
thing as
vlogs but is expanded it's basically my
vlogs on crack and and that's what
genius brains is another question that
people have been asking is what is
genius brains and I read a comment where
somebody was like don't you think that
it's kind of conceited to call yourself
genius brain you dumb [ __ ] if you listen
to the first podcast genius brains is a
sarcastic saying like it's um it's what
I used to say to people who I thought
were always trying to be too smart you
know I mean or they were way smarter
than I am so I'd be like what's going on
genius brains and it's basically sarcasm
it's basically somebody who's dumb and
that's basically what I am I'm a dumb
person just with a lot of thoughts and
ideas and a lot of jokes and genius
brain podcast if you guys want to know
what this is about we're just gonna be
talking about anything and everything in
terms of topics current events news and
just what I've been thinking about
during the week that we could just have
fun and shoot the [ __ ] about and I
didn't want genius brains to be
predicated on having a lot of celebrity
guests and I know that's
counterintuitive to what a lot of people
think I should or shouldn't do because
if you do have guests who are prevalent
in this space which I will have I just
didn't want this podcast to be based on
who comes on here rather than the
content that's being spoken about or
sparking talking my English is terrible
anyways I just when I first started
doing YouTube
I didn't collaborate with a lot of
people and there was a reason behind
this it wasn't because I didn't like
people on this space and what had
nothing to do with that had everything
to do with the fact that before I
started to work with people I had to
create a foundation for myself I had to
really solidify myself as a creator
because I didn't want to work on a
project with somebody else and then
people Know Who I am from that and say
well you got your start because this
person gave you a hand they give you a
leg up and I [ __ ] hated that [ __ ] I
hated that stuff because it was very it
kind of minimized like the hard work
that I put in to get where I was going
to be or where I was at because I didn't
want somebody saying that my success was
based on somebody else's hard work and
that's that's really what it boiled down
to and the same thing with this podcast
I don't want this podcast to be based on
the guests that I bring I want to be
based on the conversations that's let's
have that that we have on this space
right so genius brain I'm bringing in
anybody that I know somebody that I find
interesting somebody that has an
interesting story that wants to tell it
on this podcast or talk about a topic
that we can just go back and forth with
and you know celebrities to that yeah
they have an interesting story too but
everybody has an interesting story
there's just a lot of people don't have
the platform to go ahead and tell it to
people and that's generally how I gain
all my stories right I talked to a lot
of people it's it's it's Who I am as a
person I have a lot of different friends
I have a lot of conversations with
random people all the [ __ ] time which
is why I always had something to share
you know I'm always going out I'm always
up and about I'm not afraid to have a
conversation with a stranger and this is
how I number one collect stories this is
how I have stories this is how I
experience life and see things that it
with a different lens compared to most
people so that's what genius brains is
about it's it's it's an interesting move
I understand and if another thing that
people were asking was does that mean
that will only see a podcast content on
this page no it doesn't so the podcast
is going to be my main focuses here I
want to tackle that and remember said
remember what I said I can't be a jack
of all shits I had to focus on one thing
but the other thing is is that I do
still create and I'm still writing all
the time the difference is is I don't
want to have the pressure of having to
create a new series or these sketches on
a consistent basis when I don't feel
inspired to do it it's an art form right
and when you're trying to force somebody
to create art consistently on the space
without break and specifically when it
comes to sketches and short films they
think they rarely turn out really good
in my personal opinion it's just the
same [ __ ] you see over and over so you
know when we did [ __ ] goop was like a
year to two year process it took a
minute you know and the reason why we
were we got into Sundance and we sold it
to Netflix was because of the time that
we took for it I'm not saying that all
the stuff that I'm going to do was gonna
be of that caliber but I want the time
to go ahead and develop that but in the
meantime genius brains is there I want
genius brain to be that pot
caste that gets you through your day I
want it to be the podcast that you said
for number one laughs or inside or just
great conversation to follow you
throughout the day on your commute or
whatever so obviously that's gonna be
highly based on you guys loving it and
sharing and if you guys love it make
sure that you do share genius brain
podcast it's on all audio platforms
specifically iTunes Spotify cast box and
a few other stuff too you guys will see
it there so what you guys can do if you
guys love it
only if you love it which I'm pretty
sure you do because I love you and if
you don't love me then [ __ ] you is go to
iTunes and give us that that five star
rating it's gonna really help out and
I'm here like I don't want to leave this
space I just want to constantly be able
to evolve and move forward I'm not sure
if you guys are at that crossroads right
yeah I'm not sure if you guys are at
that crossroads yet in your life but
there is going to be a time where you if
you're somebody that likes to push your
boundaries where you're gonna start to
feel stagnant you're gonna start to feel
that even though you're successful and
what you're doing now there's there's
something more that you want to reach
for and it's a hard constant for people
who aren't motivated to really
understand and wrap their head around
because in their minds they're like it's
working you're making a lot of money why
do you want to [ __ ] with this formula
it's not about that sometimes if
everything was just about money then I
probably would have just worked a stable
regular job and when I first started on
this platform I didn't know that you
could make money like that it wasn't
something that that was that was on the
table for me for me when I started
youtube I just wanted to be like the
best stand-up comedian ever and I wanted
to find the means to do that and YouTube
was the platform to get me there
later on I found out that Stan it wasn't
something that I actually wanted it's
something that I still enjoyed till this
day but the only thing that I really
wanted to do was be able to tell stories
and connect with people and that
essentially is what this podcast is
that's what YouTube is that's what all
these social media platforms are and so
yeah genius brains is that next step for
me so don't worry I'm here to stay I'm
not going anywhere and I just you know
and you guys understand too like what if
I put out that video and I said I'm done
with YouTube forever like all these
[ __ ] YouTube [ __ ] do and clearly
clearly they're not they're just doing
it for the views like I just don't want
to do that and even
my thumbnails where my topics were a
little racy I always had that topic it
within the video and I still want to
stick to that that person that I am so
yeah man come with me on this journey
man genius brains is here to stay man
it's gonna be great conversations and
remember if you guys want me to talk
about a certain topic it could be
anything I'm talking about a news
article that you saw or something
controversial that's going on like I'm
most likely I'm not gonna do that much
research on it I'm gonna read up about
it here and there and you're kind of
Spinball it but this is not a new site
this is not this is not a new source
this is just people having a
conversation about anything and
everything and you know don't be afraid
to write in comments and chime in
believe that hate off and just be open
to other people having a different
opinion about certain things I got more
reading certain comments right now that
I have to block which I which I probably
won't in the future I just want those
idiots to say what they want to say but
just people being angry for no [ __ ]
reason and that's cool I guess I mean I
guess that's what you know the the power
of a podcast is people just I don't know
they think they want to be heard 24/7
but anyways that's the explanation for
genius brain podcast this is why we
switched over this is why I didn't do
the announcement and so I hope you guys
are here to stay remember these vlogs on
crack take me with you on your on your
every day take me with you on your
commute when you work out or whatever
but we're gonna have some dope
conversations that uh that's gonna get
you thinking and gonna get you laugh and
I promise you that so remember check us
out on iTunes Spotify casts box and all
of the audio platforms if you're on
iTunes please please please give us that
five star because you know I'm not
ashamed to ask for that little help you
know the YouTube channel really isn't
making money and I'm just uh yeah
sucking some dick you know I'm saying
salty this is a very weird note to end
on